carina jetzt haben wir eine
mindestschwelle auch beschlossen
bundesweit bis auf sachsen anhalt 50
euro werk eine maske tragen will
jetzt haben wir aber wenn man sich
umschaut im land und auch man mit den
menschen spricht nicht unbedingt ein
problem mit dem bußgeld dass das zu
gering wäre sondern eher das eintreiben
ist ja das problem wie will man das denn
angehen dass tatsächlich auch bußgelder
jetzt erhoben werden beispielsweise in
der deutschen bahn oder in der u-bahn
ja du sprichst einen sehr wichtigen
punkt an das ist nicht nur bei den
bußgeldern so sondern auch bei der
quarantäne bei der umsetzung das problem
ist einfach die durchsetzung also es
fehlt an allen ecken und enden es fehlt
an personal steht übrigens auch in dem
papier man will natürlich an den
entsprechenden stellen nachschärfen und
mehr personal bekommen allerdings
funktioniert das ja nicht von heute auf
morgen so personal muss ja auch
ausgebildet und erstmal irgendwie
beworben werden aber davon mal abgesehen
sieht man ja schon bei dieser idee die
es jetzt gibt das eben in der bahn wenn
man dagegen die masken pflicht verstößt
das da die bahn mitarbeiter für
zuständig sein sollen und das zeigt ja
einfach schon dass das einfach
ausgelagert wird auf andere stellen die
da de facto jetzt erstmal nicht für
zuständig sind und das sehe ich
ehrlicherweise auch kritisch weil die
polizei ist ganz anders ausgestattet und
wir haben immer wieder jetzt auch von
vorfällen gehört von aggressivität also
wirklich von zusammenstößen wenn leute
eben gegen regeln verstoßen haben und
dann sich dagegen gewehrt haben bezahlen
zu müssen
da kann man sich schon mal die frage
stellen und dieses szenario sich
ausmalen wie das dann in so einem zug
abläuft wenn es da hitzige diskussionen
gibt und der schaffner am ende das
irgendwie umsetzen muss alleine ohne
unterstützung